ah ouais c'est l'amour
salvatore et on voulait te rendre un
petit hommage juliette à des cassis je
vais commencer adamo vous permettez
monsieur jamais de votre fille bon
pierji tombe même à sauter ans
oui il aura tant en tu connais il ya des
chansons d'amour quand je t'ai vu
jérusalem copico monsieur que votre que
j'emprunte je crois bien qu'elle les
filles pompiers
je pense que c'est un s'il vous plaît
bien comment ça madame o si je ne viens
maison bleue adossée sa maman je vais
très bien alors il est très costaud à
d'amour je vais vous dire il nous
enterrera tous d'abord vous avez survécu
et la belgique
vous êtes arrivé en belgique à l'âge de
4 ans wiland sicile mais parfaitement
survécu oui on s'y soigner ses survécu à
une méningite de la moelle épinière
l'âge de 7 ans ensuite en 84 j'ai
survécu un triple pontage coronarien
vous aviez beaucoup ou fumier beaucoup
n'ont jamais fumé nom et vous savez
pourquoi rien n'a rien d'accord donc
c'est non mais j'étais sportif
enfin je me suis toujours je n'ai jamais
bu excessivement donc années le stress à
c'est le stress qui nous a valu ce ce
triple pontage coronarien
on peut dire également qu'à l'époque du
baiser à couilles rabattues je ne
dénonce rien c'est dans les livres de
berna
et on peut dire qu'elle apprend que les
uns technique et on la belle réputation
en un mot vous avez survécu à une
surdité de l'oreille droite comment est
il paralysie du côté droit du visage
oui c'est vrai pas un certain temps
jamais quand elle chante et j'arrive à
chanter en stéréo produits j'avais la
bouche de côté monsieur lavis je crois
qu'on peut le dire aussi
adam est donc 300 c'est une chance de
plus d'avoir un cancer du sein et donc
ça vous est pas arrivé
bah oui apport énorme il est toujours là
il est super bonne 102 et adamo 1 et
donc malgré tout ça vous êtes devenu
adamo une énorme star mondiale de la
chanson vous avez vendu 90 millions de
disques dans le monde
ça laisse rêveur tombe la neige tombe la
neige
à l'été rock qui plus de 500 fois vous
avez rempli trois stades le même jour en
amérique du sud etc ou fais pas chier
que ce soit toujours johnny qui se tape
les belles gonzesses officiellement
quand on parle de vous on dit toujours
que vous êtes une énorme star au japon
est ce que c'est une manière finalement
de dire qu'on remplit pas les salles en
france
dieu merci non d'ailleurs j'ai un peu
atténué comme même cette réputation
japon c'est vrai que je suis connue
c'est vrai que j'ai eu quelques succès
maintenant quand j'y vais les salles
sont pleines je suis pas en tête détails
j'ai un public fidèle ouais et en france
ça fait cinq ans que je suis revenu en
tournée les salles sont pleines les
salles sont pleines et au japon par
exemple votre notoriété pour qu'on
comprenne bien par rapport à un type
comme but de villa par exemple quel
niveau plus connu que 19 ans des
générations de le dépend des générations